let's watch the next one 15 really
personal questions you should consider
asking on a first date if you don't want
to waste your time do you want kids
do you want to be in a monogamous
relationship
do you want to get married one day who
did you vote for in the last election
who do you first go to for support how
often do you drink or do drugs how done
are you with your ex how important is
religion to you what's your main
priority in life how often do you want
to do it how adventurous are you in bed
when an argument happens do you
initially want to process it or get some
space would you ever be open to
relationship therapy you do want to be
careful that your first date doesn't
become like a Law and Order
interrogation scene where you're going
through 20 questions how long were you
with your ex what are your priorities in
life like you want to be a little bit
careful with that and asking somebody on
a first date if they be open to
relationship counseling I just met you
five seconds ago and you're asking me if
I'm ready to be in counseling with you
that's that's a million red flags all at
once